almas why don't you give an overview to
the audience of your diamond approach
for those who are unfamiliar with it and
perhaps if you like you can compare and
contrast it to advaita vedanta but you
may have to give an example of what that
is as well
well
uh
i teach a particular
approach to
actualizing the total human potential
and really what we find out if we
explore the hurricane potential that
most of it is
not conscious it's not the physical and
the emotional that's just the surface
so
a big part of it is the spiritual sphere
and
matter of spirits
so the
teaching is mostly about us is
how to
open up or to access the spiritual
dimension
of our reality for existence
and in my approach i use western
methodology like i use western
psychology for instance i integrate that
as part of the methodology
of how to open up
i use inquiry which is sort of like
similar to socratic inquiry
as a particular method
that for me is more important than
acidic meditation although we employ
sitting meditation too of different
kinds
but the idea is to find out
what the hell are we
what's going on
what am i what am i
what is the world universe what is the
nature of the universe that's how i
started actually why it started in
science
i want to know what is the truth of
reality
so i went
very far
as you know in studying physics and math
until at some point i realized i wasn't
getting it i wasn't that's not
for me i wasn't getting what where i
wanted to go i didn't know
consciously where i wanted to go
but as i
got deeper into
physics and awesome
conversing with scientists and
i realized that
it's a it's a approach is
good wonderful and very useful i'm
interested in it i love it all of that
and i was good at it
it it was from here up
you know didn't include the heart
didn't
include other capacities we have
so the approach uses
as i use i said uses inquiry but uses
the scientific methods in some kind of
way
which means i have it has to be verified
not by experiment as done in physic but
by experience
but one's own direct experience not what
i hear not what i learned from teaching
what i can verify and repeatedly
and then come verifying other people
and other people to
which at the beginning where my friends
my students
was that the teaching was developing
so and but it is
what uh what developed is a certain
perspective
about the spiritual dimension
that the spiritual dimension is not just
one thing
it's not like experience consciousness
and you know what consciousness is and
that's it
you see adveda vedanta for instance
is
[Music]
teaching about realization of pure
consciousness
to recognize that
one is that one's true self
is pure consciousness
that
has no limits
no size no shape
and that it is also the nature of
everything
and
that is part of the teaching i i give
but my teaching is not as a little bit
more nuanced i would say
because that has more detail and some
people think of it as more complex
but
because
the
the spiritual dimension for me is not
just one dimension
like consciousness for me is one
dimension
emptiness another dimension which
buddhism emphasizes
love is another dimension
you see
and creative dynamism what makes things
happen
you see very don't they don't
differentiate those that much i mean
they include them in consciousness but
sort of implicitly so i differentiate
into different dimension and then those
dimension can also
express themselves in human experience
and the physics
as particle what i call spiritual
qualities
therefore spiritual qualities like the
quality of clarity
the quality of compassion
quality of sincerity
quality of
will
you see steadfastness
and there are many of those qualities i
know at least 40 or 50 of those i don't
think i know all of them
they're similar to what's called the
platonic
ideas you see in some sense there are
the platonic ideas be behind
what we know like when we say love many
human beings fears love
but what is the platonic idea of love
what is the true
spiritual
counterpart to what a human being called
love and turns out to be a very
particular way of experiencing
consciousness
so
my approach is basically is how to learn
about the spiritual qualities which make
us be able to connect to the spiritual
sphere
which in my work the emphasis is in
presence and
ontological present
the presence of consciousness
not just conscious as a function of
consciousness as the presence the
beingness of it
and then
connection to the more of the non-dual
which is similar to advaita vedanta
and then
recognize the nun duel has more nuances
and
and then connecting the non-dual with
the ordinary life how is it
how would we leave if we are if i'm
infinite consciousness how do i live a
human life
what lives and how do i live
and that of course
a big part of the spiritual
realization of most teachings you see
and so i teach that too i work with that
but then i i leave the door open
for
uh the spiritual universe to reveal
other possibilities because there are
other possibilities of knowing reality
for instance
which really go into it takes us back
similar to some of the physics quantum
theory
you know um
household perspective
well
let me
give this example
if you have
a
buddhist master
and vader master
sitting in the same room
the buddha says
nature reality is emptiness and that's
what the experience what the person
experienced
emptiness is
the spacious emptiness
is what i experience it is the
fundamental ground
the advaita without the person says no
the
fundamental
nature of reality is pure consciousness
this is conscious of itself
and it's not emptiness it's
characterized by being
while the buddhists say characterized by
non-being
now they're both right in my perspective
but each one of them says this is the
ultimate
so how can they be both alternate
and
in my exploration i find out that
they're both correct
however if
what is really there is the ultimate
fundamental truth how come people
experience it so differently
and so my
through my own investigative spiritual
investigation the tradition and my
experience and
is that
the
how we experience what is the truth
depends on the experiencer
on the in the person
different people can experience it
differently there are different ways
reality reality manifests
so the experiencer
is what makes reality appear in a
certain way
that brings us to quantum theory
you see the experience that is needed
for
the
for the
for the quantum wave to collapse to be
to manifest in a certain way
before that we don't know what it is
so the observer that's what
quantum theory says
here you know it is the experiencer
similar to that but the experiencer is
experiencing
inward reality instead of experimenting
observing something external
so i i
i look at the spiritual realization as
i have what's called the quantum theory
of spirituality
which is that
that the spiritual
truth
is indeterminate
until we experience it
and how we experience it depending it
depends on our world view our
view of reality
depends on our expectation but it
depends on our readiness and openness
so that for me explains many traditions
why there are so many tradition
you know
different kind of teachings